Film Courage: LaKeith, I understand you used
Google searches to break into acting?
LaKeith Stanfield: Yeah…I just got out of
high school, trying to figure out what I want
to do.
Well, I kind of knew what I wanted to do,
I wanted to act in some capacity.
So I started Googling acting schools, acting
stuff, anything that encompassed acting, trying
to find a channel in.
I just Googled everything and pages and pages
of things popped up and then I just filled
everything out and then eventually people
started answering.
And a lot of those were scams and things where
I would ultimately end up wasting my time.
So I ended up going back and forth to Victorville,
scrounging up change.
One time it was a school for modeling and
career center?
And so they had us get up on the runway, taught
us to walk the runway.
And taught us all the names of the brands,
Fendi, Gucci, Prada.
They were names that were of no use to me
really.
But at the time I realized every other week
they had agents come in for people who were
inspired to get into acting.
So I wanted to get in front of one of those
agents.
And when one of those agents came through
“I want to go in!”
Every audition day was Thursday and they said
“Well, do you have anything prepared?”
And I said “Yes.”
I didn’t, but I went in anyway.
And I just did the first thing that came to
my mind which was to jump up on the chair
and be like…and do some random stuff.
And the guy saw something in me that he liked
and he signed me to his commercial agency.
And there I learned what it meant to do auditions
and fail and learn what it meant to get rejected
but be in the room and improve my comfortability
over time.
So it would prove to be a very important chapter.
Although at the time I thought I was just
wasting my time.
It proved to be really important once I got
out there and started auditioning.
I felt comfortable because I’d been rejected
and I had been through it all already and
there was nothing left to fear.
So yeah…that was what came of the Internet.
Film Courage: And I understand you didn’t
have a car while you were in Victorville?
LaKeith Stanfield: No.
Film Courage: And from what I know I don’t
think the bus really runs there from Los Angeles?
LaKeith Stanfield: No.
There’s a train that runs there.
You’ve got to scramble up some change and
take the train.
Film Courage: Okay, but that sounds like it’s
several stops.
So how are you going on auditions?
Or even to this modeling class/school and
coming back [to Victorville]?
That sounds like a lot.
LaKeith Stanfield: Half of it was just trying
to hustle up money just to get down on the
train.
And some of it was my parents.
They would help me every now and again to
take me, whenever my bugging them to go…”Fine..Whatever.
Again?
For what?”
Because when you are beginning auditioning
you don’t realize how many rejections involved
in it.
So you get rejected 20, 30 times and you are
like “What am I still doing this for?
Obviously it’s not going to work.”
And it was so much work for us to get down
there, they were just like “This is becoming
more of an expense than anything.”
And so I had to figure out ways to get down
there on my own after awhile.
And I missed a lot of auditions because I
couldn’t make it.
And that was sad because at the time I hated
missing them.
I would rather get rejected than to miss it,
you know?
Film Courage: What’s your advice for another
actor that maybe they don’t have the formal
training but they know they really want to
do this?
What would you advise them?
What would they be Googling?
LaKeith Stanfield: I don’t know?
Now there is probably 900 pages when I Googled
acting, probably 9 million now.
So there’s much more to weed from.
Much more opportunity to get caught up in
different things.
I would say stay in school, stay diligent,
go through high school, go through college,
and try to look through opportunities after
having sort of learned all you can learn and
situate yourself and be comfortable before
you get into acting.
Know that there is something else that you
could be doing.
Know that you have a back-up plan because
this is a very difficult, tough game to get
into.
And it’s tough to maintain even once you’re
in.
It’s not like just because you booked something
you are going to be working forever.
So you always have to keep that hustle up
and continue to look for new avenues and know
that if this doesn’t work, you’ve got
something else in the back and if that don’t
work, you got something else.
You have other alternatives, as well.
And don’t focus all of your energy on acting
would be my thing.
Film Courage: Did you ever feel pushback from
people, from even other actors who maybe were
classically trained and they saw you booking
more work and they were like “Well, you
didn’t try this technique…”
And you could feel that, maybe it wasn’t
even spoken?
LaKeith Stanfield: Oh yeah.
Totally.
It wasn’t spoken and it was spoken in certain
parts.
But everybody’s got their particular route.
One thing I think is important to being an
actor is always keep an open mind, always
be willing to learn, and don’t reach a point
where you feel like I’ve learned enough
and now I don’t need to know anything else.
Because your talent will take you so far but
you need to be constantly trying to develop
skills and learning how to access these characters
and analyze these stories and tell them in
the most authentic way.
And while your talent will take you a long
way, it won’t take you to the heights that
you want to go because there’s a cap, a
moment where you’re like “Well, this is
just about my talent.”
You need to constantly stretch yourself, travel,
meet new people, engage in new experiences
(fearlessly) and sort of download that information
into creating what you want to create.
Every role is different, so what may work
for one role, may not work for another and
vice versa.
So sometimes your talent will be great for
a certain role and then for another role you
have to reach outside the boundaries of your
natural talent in order to tap into it.
Those are things that I find the most rewarding
and the most difficult and they cause me to
have to get studious and learn all of these
things, you know?
And get into these different lifestyles and
understanding.
So always keep an open mind and I think you
can explore and do whatever you need to do.
And realize, remember this game is not a competition.
It seems like a competition, but it’s not.
The only person you’re in competition with
is yourself.
If you think you can’t do a certain thing,
you can’t.
If you think you can, you can.
You’ve just got to push yourself.
Film Courage: Have there ever been roles that
you don’t want to take, for whatever reason?
You don’t believe in the project or there
is something about the character that you
just wouldn’t feel good about playing?
LaKeith Stanfield: Totally, yeah.
Characters are realizations from people’s
imaginations.
So naturally some of are going to fit with
your imagination and some aren’t.
And some are based off of real people and
are accurate depictions and some aren’t.
So you have to use discernment to figure out
what speaks to you, what’s real to you.
I think when you first start you are going
to take anything that comes at you because
you’re trying to work, that’s understandable.
That’s what I did.
I think most actors do that when they are
first starting out because they need to work
because it’s a job.
But once you start to develop the craft you
can weed out what speaks to you and what is
important.
Because it’s also important to do things
that correlate with your frequency, that go
with how you are attempting to move.
Because if it doesn’t, you are portraying
something that isn’t genuine.
And then your performance, people are going
to see it and say “There’s something that
isn’t genuine about that?”
So make sure it connects to you.
This is why I think it’s important to expand
your horizon and awareness so then more things
have the opportunity to click with you.
The more broad your horizon, the more chance
you are able to say “Oh, yeah.
I know what that is.”
Rather than living in a sort of vacuum.
If something is coming into your awareness,
you might be like “Hmmm, that’s too foreign.
I don’t know what that is.”
And never judge the character.
Film Courage: What did Colin teach you about
life?
LaKeith Stanfield: Colin Stark?
Playing him [Colin Warner from CROWN HEIGHTS]
in this movie he sort of reestablished the
idea to persevere in the face of insurmountable
odds, continue to push forward and remain
steadfast in what you believe in.
And the more you do that, the more you may
realize what you were attempting to realize.
Break the chains of whatever chains that are
on you…there are physical chains and psychological
chains.
Stay the course and you can eventually break
them.
Film Courage: Did you feel pressure playing
someone who was very much still alive, knowing
that the film would mean very much to them?
LaKeith Stanfield: To an extent, yes.
I think that I was lulled by a great team
that I was around.
Colin himself being in it helped a lot and
made me feel that he’s with us in this,
so I’m at ease.
He believes in the story, he believes in the
ability, so we’re just going to move forward
in the spirit of that.
Also, I was blessed by his family.
He took me into their house and blessed me
at this little…sort of like…shrine thing
where they blessed me.
So I felt like I got the spirit…so we just
went from there.